hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and I'm excited to talk to you today
about trading uh order flow in the
crypto markets now you know that there
aren't a lot of platforms out there that
let you analyze a footprint chart on
crypto markets and you know I've been a
big advocate of ninjatrader for you know
almost the last decade it seems and you
know one of the problems was the
analyzing the the footprint chart with
um cryptos and it was kind of difficult
because yeah while ninjatrader you do
have uh access to the coinbase data feed
for free you problem was
um you know the way that it was handling
the data was putting a big strain on the
footprint charts and you know plus you
know add to that you know really they
only have a couple of the contracts set
up you have to literally manually go in
and set up you know all the other uh
coins other than Bitcoin and ethereum
and it's just kind of a royal uh pain in
the butt to do it and you know go
charting is a web-based platform
that allows you to pull up a footprint
chart in a matter of you know just a few
clicks it uses the same data feed
because you know I don't know I I use
coinbase for my crypto uh trading I
don't know do we really trade crypto or
you just buy and hold um it seems that
like for me
um and the people I know we just buy and
hold but you know there are people out
there that do like to trade crypto on an
intraday basis and you know go charting
if you haven't looked at go charting
it's something that you should look at
you know I'll just give you some of the
the benefits as opposed to you know go
charting versus say ninjatrader you know
go charting is a web-based platform so
you could access the charts
um you know from anywhere without having
to install software on your PC right
ninjatrader you have to download desktop
software I mean yeah technically they do
have a web version coming out I don't
know where that is in the timeline
um you know guard go charting has a
pretty intuitive interface optimized for
order flow Trading ninjatrader you know
it's there's a learning curve involved
um
you know goal charting has already in it
Advanced order flow tools and recently
They just added my order flows Trader
Suite so you know one of the other
benefits is it's
the the fees right for the charting
right go charting has very low
subscription fees compared to ninja
Traders
um platform fee right if you want a to
buy the platform from ninjatrader it's
going to cost you like thirteen hundred
dollars and you know and then you got to
learn how to use the software it's very
difficult for some people you know trust
me I've
I've
sent a lot of customers new traders to
ninjatrader over the years
um you know that wanted to trade order
flow and you know there is a certain
percentage that just you know throw
their hands up in the air with Ninja
trades yeah I can't it's too complicated
for me to learn but you know to each
their own so
one of the things that I like about go
charting is you know all the crypto
pairs are there and
you know you just want to have a system
that you don't have to sit there and you
know manually add the contract to so for
example right you know me I'm a Futures
guy right I trade Futures but I do get a
lot of interest from people that want to
use order flow
on the cryptos and
the thing with trading order flow is you
know you want to make sure your data is
um you know has Integrity is legit right
you don't want to be getting data from
some puny exchange that doesn't do a lot
of volume so you know coinbase is you
know in my opinion a very solid exchange
they do a lot of volumes one of the
largest exchanges out there and you know
the data is reliable and what's nice is
you know I think you can subscribe to
the data from code charting it's it's
nothing it's like 20 a month you know
whatever but you know you got you got
everything in there so for example right
if you want to pull up the Bitcoin chart
now you can see in here right you've got
you know one inch against Bitcoin uh you
know cardano against Bitcoin Etc and you
can see which exchange is coming from
coinbase coinbase coinbase coinbase
coinbase you know all these
um different coins it's already there
you could pull up the chart and it'll
just come right up so let me just uh
find you know the very basic one
um
I don't know we'll do Bitcoin versus
dollar okay because you know I'm an
American and here you go that's your
footprint right there okay you got all
your your volume your Delta
um and then when you start adding in
things like my order flows Trader uh
Suites right you gotta
other ways to analyze
the data you know so it's a great way to
use order flow on crypto right and again
you know whether you want to look at you
know this is a five minute chart you can
do um you know a 30 minute chart and see
how fast it is it's like it's instant
right you don't have to sit here and
wait you know processing or something
it's very quick right that's a 30 minute
chart you know maybe you want to use uh
oh
to our chart okay it's going here you go
boom now again you could expand it a bit
you know to open it up
um you can make it bigger smaller uh you
can do it you could do a lot of things
with uh
with go charting right this is one
minute right obviously there's gonna be
little bits of gaps in here uh you know
on the one minute chart
for Bitcoin I don't know I like to use
five minutes and
um you know 30 minutes and one hour but
you can see where there's imbalances in
here now again you know
one of the differences when analyzing
uh Bitcoin versus Zaya Futures is you
know Futures it's one contract right
whereas Bitcoin you know you could buy
ten dollars worth and you know you have
to take that data and and put it into
something useful plus also you know it
trades the way Bitcoin trades you know
you could buy it at uh 29
000 420 spot zero zero six seven five
right and so you know you're going to
want to aggregate the prices
um you know into something
usable because you don't want to be you
know on your axis of your chart being
twenty nine thousand four one five spot
uh zero zero zero zero zero one then
spot zero zero zero zero two it's about
zero zero zero three that was one of the
problems that uh I was facing with
uh ninjatrader okay but all the other
coins I mean so you want the ship people
people ask me yo what what coins you
hold I I actually still hold uh ship
um you know outside of Bitcoin but
you know there's ways you can analyze
this data that's very useful this is uh
some of the the signs in from the order
flows Trader right these you see these
red arrows which is bearish here coming
in
um you know right before this little
sell-off but uh you know there's so many
different ways you could analyze
order flow on crypto is go charting is
really a game changer in my opinion now
I do realize that there is one or two
other uh sort of competitors to go
charting that do offer
um a web-based footprint chart but they
don't have a lot of the tools the one
nice thing about go charting which
really
um
I can appreciate because you know as an
order flow Trader and software developer
you know I've worked with a lot of
programmers over the years and not all
of them understand order flow but the
guys at go charting
they're all in on overflow they they
understand order flow backwards forwards
you know I've had a lot of chats with
them
um just on the markets in general not
just crypto but you know the US markets
the India markets and you know they
understand it right they understand its
importance and Order flow for them is
you know a priority it's not something
like oh we have a charting platform
let's put a footprint chart on there
because you know a lot of people like to
trade overflow no these guys they get it
right they understand it and sometimes
you know when we're working together to
put my uh
order flows Trader platform on their
platform you know my add-in
um
you know I didn't have to sit there and
spend an hour explaining to him I said
you know this is what I wanted to do you
know it looks at this relationship
between you know the Delta and the
volume Etc here then it should highlight
this bar and things like that you know
they they understand it and that's
important right because
um you know a lot of people like to copy
things right but they don't they copy
things without understanding it but you
know at least the guys go charting
they understand it right and when things
that they don't understand they come to
me because I created a lot of these
tools that are out there with order flow
that have been copied by other vendors
um you know this is uh so that ship
right
um you know Doge
you know if you want to pull up Doge and
people laugh at me with these these
coins but um
you know
there's your footprint right it's nice
nice and very easy to see whether you
want to look at it on a on a five minute
chart or you know an hourly chart you
know if you want to add the value areas
you know it's really simple
um or you hear about you here he is here
to do you know
extend it up make it a little bit it's
kind of white it's a little hard to see
make it a bit gray change the opacity
um you know one of my favorite things
you know which I convinced them to add
and they made it sort of a native thing
in there
whoops that's the web marker uh or my
value area extension here is to draw out
these areas of value area right
this is you know I said you know if
anything you got to put it in there
you'll make it a default setting so all
users can can use it not just uh
users of the order flows Trader because
it's a very powerful tool right you have
value areas overlapping then you have a
value area here and then you don't trade
back into value Market's starting to
move away from value that's important
information as a Trader right imagine
right this is
what is this Doge sorry I forget even
though it says right here node us uh D
um you know that's a nice move if you're
a scalper right there's you can take
advantage of these moves right and you
can see when a market is potentially
shifting to the downside so again you
know if you haven't checked it out you
got to check out go charting for trading
crypto
um
yeah honestly it's in my opinion it's
it's head and shoulders above whatever's
else is is out there
um again you know for me I don't
actively trade crypto I just buy it and
hold it just you know that's always been
my uh way of approaching crypto but
again you know I do know there's a lot
of guys out there that can lever up
quite high and take the plunge so if you
do that you've got to look at go
charting right you've got to look at it
um
I don't even know what uh
so many coins out there it is beautiful
because you know again I like to look at
the um coinbase data I don't look at
like the bit stamp stuff um you know
binance Etc
I just stick with coinbase because
that's where um
trade my crypto quote-unquote trade just
buy an old
um you know Matic here you go you know I
don't know let's uh
let's pull up uh I don't know I don't
know honestly I haven't even gone
through all the all the coins uh coin
that are out there well let's just see
let's take a look here
um
I am not a robot look at this I enter
the right thing in there only market cap
coin Market okay sorry I'm just a little
excited I don't know what the heck I
typed in there let's just find some of
these uh
coins okay
honestly I'm curious myself if some of
these
Fighters
that's a binance um yeah you're gonna
want the ones that are on coinbase I
don't know if that's listed on coinbase
um
I'll go around that was one that I was
really high on years ago we haven't
really done much
I'll go around
oh look at that right this is it's
beautiful right you can just get all
these things
in an instance right again this is uh
this is a one hour chart
it's just nice to be able to look at it
people know that it's there pull up
um
you know anytime I want in an instant
right rather than have to go in and go
through the uh setting up you know the
contract and ninja Trader
um you know then then get the data it's
a pain in the butt it's just nice to
have that there again I believe you will
need to subscribe to the data feed but
the data feed is only like 20 bucks or
something like that so it's uh it's a
good deal anyway guys
I hope uh you know this gets you
interested in
uh go charting so you know if you're
interested in it my order flow tools are
available right now for free until the
end of uh August of which you know at
which point they'll become
um
you know a paid add-on but again it'll
be a small amount and you know there's
just so much that you can do with the
order flow in terms of analysis it's
just going to give you an edge over
everybody else that's out there you're
trading against because remember you
know you're not just
um
you know trading you're trading against
other people and information which is
provided in the order flow
it gives you an advantage in my opinion
over everybody else it's all right
everybody I'll end it there you know I
do have a link in the description if
you're interested in go charting to get
started so I'll see you guys on the next
video bye-bye